- Even more important
than where it came from.
The Chinese leadership
knew that they had a pretty
contagious, relatively
lethal virus on their hands
by the fall of '19,
and decided to put
tens of thousands of people
on airplanes and murder.
And I say that
intentionally, murder
hundreds of thousands of
people all across this country.
They had a choice to make.
The choice they made
was load airplanes,
send them to Milan, Italy.
The Chinese Communist Party
must be held accountable
for this.
Look, they don't care
about human life, so be it.
But when you transmit that
to the rest of the world
and you kill people
all around the world,
there's a place for
real accountability.
(dramatic music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is the former
director of the CIA,
a former secretary of state
and author of the new book,
"Never Give an Inch: Fighting
for the America I love,"
Secretary Mike Pompeo. Welcome
to, "The Rubin Report."
- Dave, it's great
to be with you.
- I mentioned to you
right before we started
that I just did an hour
show blowing up the people
of the World Economic Forum,
and now I get to talk
to an actual American,
so I'm very relieved
at the moment.
That's how we're
starting this interview
with just relief on my part.
I hope that's okay with you.
- That is a great way
to begin an interview.
- And you did note that
you are not in Davos.
Can I ask where you are?
- Yeah, I'm in my home.
I'm in Virginia today.
- Great. Great.
All right. Well, there's a ton
to talk to you about obviously.
Before we get into
all of the CIA stuff
and secretary of state
stuff and Trump stuff
and Biden stuff,
and all that stuff,
can you gimme like
a minute or two,
just kind Mike Pompeo 101
little bit of your history
that led you to doing
all of these things?
- Oh, goodness.
So, look, I grew up in
Santa Ana, California.
My parents wanted to chart a
better life for their kids.
I have a older sister,
younger brother,
much like many
parents in America.
And then I got really lucky,
I got into West Point,
and so went to the United
States Military Academy,
served little over five
years on active duty.
I had a great assignment.
Ronald Reagan was my
commander in chief.
I was patrolling the East
German border in my M1 tank.
There's not much better
for a 22-year-old kid
than rolling up and down
a Soviet communist border
in a M1 tank.
It's all really good stuff.
And then I went to law school,
practiced law for
a couple of years,
and started a company in Kansas
with my three best friends
in the whole world,
married to a lovely
woman named Susan.
We have one son, Nick,
who's now 32 years old
and married to a great
Christian lady named Rachel.
And then I lost my mind after
about eight or nine years
in the private sector,
ran for Congress, and
that led me to ultimately
getting the opportunity
to serve America
in the Trump administration
in those two roles.
- All right. That's the
abbreviated bio let's say.
Let me start this way for the
real portion of the interview.
Right now when
people say CIA, FBI,
when people are hearing
all of what's going on
with the Twitter
files and seeming
government intelligence
agency collusion with big tech
and all of these
things, there's a real,
I think, warranted skepticism
about these agencies.
So, can you just talk
to us a little bit about
what the agencies are like?
Is all of this stuff warranted,
is some of our worries
unwarranted, et
cetera, et cetera?
- No. The concern of
governmental power
is one of the reasons I
ran for Congress, right?
Too much power in
Washington, D.C. unchecked
is something that America has
always had a responsibility
to protect against,
and you can see it.
I can speak most directly to
of the intelligence agencies,
the CIA.
I worked with the
FBI on some projects,
but I was never
responsible for it
in the same way that I got
a chance to peer inside CIA.
I took over from a man
named John Brennan,
the previous director
who had politicized
that agency deeply.
He'd, I write about this
in, "Never Give an Inch."
He'd worked on this thing
that incorporated
the Steele dossier
that became the
Russia hoax in ways
that were antithetical to good
analysis, good intelligence
that is so important for the
United States of America.
And I had to go back and
rebuild pieces of that.
But the good news was,
and this is different
from the State Department,
which is a big bureaucracy,
which frankly we could talk
about is hugely problematic,
but different at the CIA.
At the CIA, most of
the folks are people
who want to do
America's mission,
and so when I came in and
President Trump came in,
yes, sir, got it. This is
the direction you're going.
We're gonna go bang our
head against the wall.
We're gonna go break through it,
and we're gonna deliver
for the American people
as you have directed us to do.
These are young men and
women who, you know,
they just wanna put a
dagger in their mouth
and go out and collect
intelligence for us.
And the risk is that you
have political leadership
and in the end
presidents own that.
You have political
leadership that undermines
both America's confidence
in the institutions,
which is the skepticism
you're referring to.
But as equally bad as that,
as troubling as the absence
of confidence in
the institution is,
is they're not effective,
they're not on mission.
When they're spending their time
training on diversity,
equity, and inclusion,
when the green agenda and the
LGBTQ agenda come to dominate
the focus inside
these institutions,
you're undermining incredibly
powerful American tools
that have kept us all safe
for an awfully long time.
- So when you took the gig,
was it like day one that
you realized how politic
and the Obama staffing
and everything
that Brennan was doing, did
you realize it on day one,
how dirty the whole
thing had become
and how tough is it to go in
and try to clean up
some of that stuff?
- So I'd seen it
even before that,
I served on the House
Intelligence Committee,
so I had been watching the DNI
operation, the CIA operation,
all of the intelligence
folks for four or five years.
And so I knew that
Brennan, look,
this is a director of the
CIA who refused to say
that the agency spied on
foreigners, right? (chuckles)
- Right.
- It's task is to go do
really good collections,
so presidents can
have good data sets
to make informed decisions.
And so, I knew that Director
Brennan had taken this agency
off mission, off its focus.
And so literally it's the
case, Dave, on day one,
I went in, built my team,
some of from the outside,
most of it, frankly from the
inside, that were still great
and still are
great people there.
We identified leaders,
we identified people
who were pipehitters who
were willing to go crush it
on behalf of America and
change the focus of the agency
to deliver for the president.
- So, how has that now
changed since you are gone?
And obviously we have
a new administration
and I suspect they probably like
a lot of those
Brennan appointments
that were there, and ideas.
- Yeah. Yeah. It's different.
I will say this, the
current director,
Director Burns is
not John Brennan,
and so I think that's fantastic.
John, along with Director
Comey with the FBI,
were a pair of truly
bad actors who,
and I write about
this in the book,
who on January 6th,
2017 when the president
had not yet been sworn
in, went to Trump Tower,
I was invited to be there.
I was still just a
member of Congress,
I was the nominee to
be the CIA director,
went to Trump Tower,
basically told Donald Trump
that he was a Russian asset
or that they believed so,
and I am now even more convinced
that they knew that wasn't true.
That they knew it was
based on unreliable,
unverified for sure information.
And the harm that they did,
forget to me or to Donald Trump,
the harm that they
did to our country
is just among the most
dangerous things I have seen
come out of the intelligence
community in my lifetime.
- What do you make
of how nobody seems
to ever pay a price
for these things?
So, when you talk about
the Steele dossier
coming out of this, or the 50
former intelligence officials
that basically said
the Hunter Biden laptop
was Russian disinformation,
which we know obviously
it now was not.
I think one of the
frustrations for average people
is they see this and they go,
Well, nobody seems
to ever get fired.
Actually, the people who lie
end up with gigs on, "CNN"
or in the government.
- Yeah. One of my biggest
challenges was John Brennan
was out there on "MSNBC"
talking about all this stuff
while I was trying
to run this CIA.
It was hugely problematic
'cause you had
some fraction of the workforce
that wanted to follow him.
And more importantly,
you had this-
- Are you guys not
told beforehand?
I don't know who would
tell you, but I mean,
isn't shouldn't there
be some sort of code,
like if you ran the thing,
you can't be on "MSNBC"
or "Fox" a week after you
leave to tell the secret.
- Goodness. Yeah, yeah.
And by the way, that
was common practice,
a pretty common practice.
Look, I don't have any problem
if what you're going out there
is to talk about the
greatness of the institution
that you led and the people,
really the people, right?
But when you're out
there telling stories,
to your point about the
Russia hoax, John Brennan
and the folks who signed
that document clearly knew
that this was likely not
Russian disinformation,
and so they caveat
it to be clever.
But the truth is, I
think they all knew,
but they had a political agenda.
And that's the danger.
These institutions
matter an awful lot.
We haven't spent as much
time talking about the FBI.
But to your point
about accountability,
we know that McCabe lied.
We know that the FBI
concluded that McCabe lied,
and he's out on "CNN"
telling stories,
pretending he was a good
actor inside that institution,
when in fact he, along
with the cohort around him,
undermined the most basic
principles of our republic.
- Who do you really put the
blame at with all of this?
Like, do you feel that
that's a Brennan to blame
or was that purely
that he was doing
basically what Obama
appointed him to do?
- Dave, I always hold the
senior leaders accountable.
And that holds true for
our administration too.
The things we got wrong
were my responsibility
or the president's
responsibility.
This isn't a partisan shot,
so I hold President
Obama responsible.
In fact, with respect
to this dossier
and the intelligence
report that was written,
Obama had directed
that report be written
and publicized in the fall
of what would've been 2016
after the election.
He directed that they
write this report
and that they make
a classified version
and an unclassified
version that was released.
That's unheard of
to have that happen,
and so this was directed
from the highest levels.
Last thought, people matter.
And so every president has
to be incredibly focused
from before day one on
bringing the right people in
that not only share their policy
views, but their value set.
And I think you can see
one of the things I regret
is that Director Comey
wasn't replaced immediately
at the beginning of
our administration.
He sat inside of our
team while he was trying
to undermine everything
it was that we were doing.
- So, do you blame your
former boss for that?
Like do you think
he was just not,
didn't realize the
magnitude of the problem?
Because that is one of the
things people say, Hey, Obama,
you may not like what he did,
but he did staff these
places the way that he wanted
while Trump didn't realize
how many layers down,
something to that effect,
that that's one of the kind
of memes out there
on this thing.
- Yeah. I even think President
Trump himself has said
that he came in
new without knowing
a whole lot of folks in town,
which was a positive,
a good thing.
I'm in support of that.
But also had the
downside of the fact
that he had some
missteps at the front end
in terms of people.
The second thing is,
is we didn't get our
team on the field.
So not only were
there some selections
that weren't the right ones,
we spent an awful lot of
time waiting for our folks
to get the clearances complete,
get the Senate to confirm
them, get them in position.
We lived the first year and a
half or two of our entire time
of half of our time
working with folks
who'd been appointed by
president other than the one
that the people had elected in
November of 2016. That's bad.
Whoever the next
conservative president is,
they've got to get that right.
They gotta show up
day one, helmet on,
ready to thrive these
people into the team,
so that we have our team,
we have our leaders,
they are out executing with a
viciousness that is required
to push back against the
administrative state.
- So speaking of that
administrative state,
I'm sure you've seen some
of the Twitter file leaks
and the emails that went
from intelligence agencies
to the employees at Twitter.
I mean, were they
overstepping their bounds
and at what point is that a
violation of our first amendment
if the government is in
essence coercing a company
to silence people?
- Yeah, you can either
have command and control
or you can have coercion
in this case, right?
And the net effect is identical.
I think you can pretty
clearly see this was coercion,
so lawyers can all tell us
whether that invokes
the first right
or if you have
government action or not.
I don't really, well,
here's what we know.
We know with absolute certainty
that the political
actors in the White House
were giving guidance
to these folks
to censor conservative ideas.
Not viewpoint neutral, this is
not about keeping the Taliban
or ISIS off of Twitter.
This is about political actors
seeking to manipulate
speech in America in a way
that promoted a governmental
viewpoint, that is dangerous.
I'm happy to see that the
American people can see it,
because in the end,
Dave, you know this,
most of the recourse, to your
point about accountability,
most of the recourse
comes through political
accountability.
Justice departments are
responsive to the presidents
that put them together,
while they have a
element of independence.
Make no mistake about it.
The attorney general
works for the president
of the United States of America,
and we can see that
plain as day-to-day
in the way Merrick Garland
is delivering this
justice department
and weaponizing so much of
what they're doing there.
- So, let's talk
about that actually.
'Cause obviously the
big thing at the moment
are these classified documents.
We went through six months ago
what Trump had at Mar-a-Lago,
and the president is allowed
to declassify things.
But the media was telling you
the walls are closing in again
and okay, it doesn't seem
as if much has happened.
But now Biden's in the midst
of one of these
scandals himself.
What should the policy,
what actually is the policy
on this sort of thing?
Like, one of the things
that I've heard Biden
say a couple times is,
well, it was a small
amount of documents
as if that somehow makes
it a little bit better.
I'm pretty sure you don't want
any classified docs out, right?
Is that fair to say?
- It seems right, Dave.
If it's classified,
it has a place
and that place isn't next to
your Corvette in the garage.
By the way, it's also
not at Mar-a-Lago.
And by the way, it
wasn't on your Blackberry
when you were Hillary Clinton.
The first time I
dealt with this,
when I sat on the
Benghazi committee
with Jim Jordan and Trey Gowdy,
when you had senior
American officials
exchanging classified
information
across an unsecured Blackberry,
and you had all this stuff
in the server up at Hillary
Clinton's place in New York.
I lived this where we
were trying to unpack
exactly the risk she had created
to America by doing this.
My theory on this one,
again, not partisan,
classified information,
protect it.
If it shouldn't be classified,
if it's overclassified, fine.
Declassify it, get it out,
release it to, "The
Washington Post," sign me up.
But if the decision
was that this is needed
to protect an American
secret or American soldiers
or sailors or airmen or
marines somewhere in the world,
then for goodness sakes,
no one, not a president,
not not a CIA director
or secretary of state,
no one should be absolved
from responsibility
for managing that
information appropriately,
and so I hope this
will be managed in a
way that is neutral.
And I'd say one last thing,
Dave, neutral in two ways.
One, it shouldn't be
political, Rs, Ds,
conservatives, liberals,
but neutral also,
and I write about
this in the book.
We didn't prosecute,
we didn't get any anything
to Hillary Clinton.
There were lots of young
soldiers, young Marines,
who had made mistakes
in how they handle
classified information.
They were punished, and
so we should make sure
that you don't get off scot free
just because you have
power and influence,
and you are punished if you
are someone who is more junior,
whether you're a GS12 at
the Department of Energy
or a young private
in the Marines.
We should make sure
that in America
the law is applied evenly,
both left and right
and up and down.
- That would be refreshing.
I don't even know
if you're allowed
to answer this next question,
but how do you guys
actually decide
what really is that
highest level classified?
Is there a standard
policy on everything
or do they bring
things to your desk
and you have people
making arguments for you
that you have to make
that final call on.
- Some of each.
So there's a process, a
detailed classification process
within the United
States government.
The Department of
Defense has a process,
the intelligence agencies
each have a process.
They roughly mirror each other,
but decision makers at every
level are making decisions
about how to classify.
There are categories of things.
If there are things
about operative
somewhere in the world,
it gets a certain classified,
so there is a rubric designed
to try and get these
classification levels right.
Look at the edge.
I'm sure there's people
making judgment calls,
maybe some of them political.
I didn't see much of
that inside the CIA,
mostly I saw people
trying to get it right.
And then there were
many, many occasions
when things were brought to me,
and for whatever reason I
wanted them declassified.
I felt it was important that
the American people knew.
I thought that the risk,
whatever that might have been
two years ago, five years ago,
was diminished.
And so I would send
it back down and say,
we needed to declassify this.
A little bit of
process, but in the end,
between the senior
leadership and the president,
we could always get it to the
right level of classification.
There are a handful of
times I went the other way.
I saw something like,
"What the heck's that doing
out at in the free space.
We need to try to make sure
we secure that information
at least for a little while."
- Are you worried at all
that as people kind of see
how dysfunctional Washington is,
or just how crazy the
machine seems to be
as we've, you know,
because of technology,
we can look under
the hood now in a way
that you couldn't,
say 40 years ago that,
that we're not gonna
get the quality person
that you want working
in these agencies
because people are
just gonna say,
no, I'd rather be in
the private sector.
I just see this thing
as a big freaking mess.
I mean, I understand
you're saying
there's obviously a lot
of great people there,
but that over time
that there will be
a sort of a draining of that.
- Yes. I'm worried about
it in two respects.
One, in the true sense
that you described,
good people will decide
not worth the candle.
Yeah. For financial
reasons, family reasons,
who needs the headache
reasons, all the above.
The second reason
I worry about this,
and I write about this,
and this is why you
can't give an inch,
that's why I titled
the book the way I did.
The bias will be that
people of the left will say,
yeah, I wanna be
part of government.
And conservative will say, I
want to go live my life, right?
And that bias, I
think already exists
inside these bureaucracies.
I come from a place where
government is something
that you look at and you go,
Yeah, I'm a little skeptical.
And the private sector
should be flourishing
and delivering in
churches and synagogues,
and boy scout troops.
That's the place
America was made.
And so conservatives
tend to say,
I'm good. I'm living here.
I'm living my
great life in Texas
or my wonderful life in Southern
Illinois, wherever you are.
And say, you know, why'd
I go to Washington for,
and liberals are
dying for that power.
And so, not only do you have
a net decrease in talent
that I worry about
and excellence,
but you'll get a bias.
The best people who are
conservative thinkers,
people who are good
operators will say,
nah, I'm not gonna go do that.
- What do you do about that?
I mean, that one seems
almost unwinnable to me
because that's just
the nature of power
versus the individual.
And you're just
gonna self-select out
because you want
to go do something
in a functional free atmosphere.
And that's not really
the government.
I mean, is there any
solution to that?
- Yes, I'm gonna provide
the solution right now.
- Wow.
- To your entire audience.
- All right.
- Go spend some part
of your life serving.
Doesn't have to be
in Washington, D.C.,
it doesn't even have
to be in government.
But different people will be
in different parts
of their life.
Take a couple years, four
years, two, whatever it is,
and go serve.
You can do it as a
deacon at your church.
You can do that
coaching someone's
little league baseball team.
You can do it in
Washington, D.C.,
you can run for city council,
or even better still,
run for school board
and go fix the crap
that's being taught
in our schools today.
And so, I'm not
only gonna tell you
that there's a solution to this.
I'm gonna be part
of the solution
by urging people who
share our value system,
who understand the
Judeo-Christian
heritage of America
in the most fundamental way
and say, all right, I get it.
It's really wonderful to be
out here living my own life.
But at some point in your
20s, in your 30s, in your 50s,
whatever, go spend a
little bit of time.
This is the greatest nation of
the history of civilization.
And we each can find
a way and a place
to give back just a little bit.
- So, let's shift a little
bit to the second portion
of your job in the
Trump administration.
So you had about a, it
was about a year plus,
right, as CIA director,
and then you had the
last couple years
as the secretary of state.
Did you expect that
kind of transition?
Did the phone just ring one day?
Were you looking for a new gig?
- Yeah, a little
different than that.
I got a quick heads
up that the president
was thinking about
making a change.
It was apparent
to the whole world
that he wasn't pleased with
the current secretary of state
or then Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson,
so that didn't come
as a surprise to me.
But I got a little
bit of heads up
from then Chief of Staff Kelly.
And then one day the president
asked me to stay behind
after I had briefed
him and said,
Hey, I'm thinking about
making this change.
I'm thinking about maybe you.
I loved what I was doing, Dave,
and I had a lot of work
to do still at CIA,
and so it was very
mixed feelings.
But in the end, when the
president asked you to serve,
you do it.
It was a couple
weeks later, I think,
he called me and said, Hey,
I want you to come do this.
I of course immediately
said, yes, sir, here we go,
helmet on, let's get after it.
- And what kind
of shift is that?
'Cause obviously these are
extremely different positions.
- Big shift.
You had the glory at the CIA
of never having to
deal with the media
and immediately moved
to the State Department
where they are front and center
and they sit in the
back of your airplane
when you travel
around the world.
And you had a team
that was much bigger,
70,000 or so people
at the United States
Department of State.
And you also had a bureaucracy
that had three unions,
a set of civil service
rules that mean
you essentially
can't fire anybody.
A fundamentally
different institution
that also had good people.
But who...
It is a left of
center organization,
but even more troubling,
it is an establishment
organization.
And so whether Republican or
Democrat, that institution,
the inertia inside of
the Department of State
was something that we all just
struggled to light a fire on,
get after them, make them
effective, make them efficient,
and turn their
focus on delivering,
putting American
people first in the way
that President Trump and
I were thinking about
our place in the world.
- But you got stuff done.
- We did.
- I mean, we got a couple
peace deals in the Middle East,
which I thought everybody
was for, my whole life.
everyone was for
that sort of thing.
Suddenly when Trump does
it, it's no good, right?
- It turns out that we
didn't get the plaudits
that it's so deserved.
But in the end it isn't
about getting kudos,
in the end it's about
delivering good outcomes.
These Abraham Accords and I
spent a fair amount of time
talking about it, wasn't
just me, Jared Kushner,
Steven Mnuchin, we had
two great ambassadors,
David Friedman and John
Rakolta in the Emirates.
We had a great team just
working this problem set.
The Lord blessed us with
Prime Minister Netanyahu,
Donald Trump, Mohammed
bin Salman in the Kingdom,
MBZ in the Emirates,
great leaders,
who are prepared
to take some risks.
And the great news
is we got peace.
These nations now aren't
trying to wipe Israel
off the face of the earth.
That is a wonderfully
good thing.
But importantly for
the American people,
the chance that we
have to send our kids
to fight and die in the
Middle East now is lower.
There's more stability,
more prosperity, more peace.
And as I always
thought about it,
that was the best outcome
of the Abraham Accords.
The fact that we now have
friends and partners.
We had isolated Iran and
it was much less likely
that some president someday
is going to announce
that we're deploying
Marines and soldiers
and Air Force guys and
gals to the Middle East
to fight some Middle East War.
America doesn't need that. The
Middle East doesn't need it.
And that's why I'm just so happy
that we were able
to get that done.
- It's so weird because
even though it was only
basically three
years ago, it's like,
it feels like a
real distant memory
that this
administration, you know,
at first they were saying
don't even say Abraham Accords
and they really didn't
wanna give any credit.
How tenuous was it as you
guys were making these deals?
Like, did you feel
like at any moment
the whole thing
could fall through
or there was gonna be a leak
that was gonna ruin
it for another country
or whatever else?
- Yeah, Dave, we
suffered lots of leaks
and leaks on this particular
effort were very real
and put a lot at risk because
you had Middle East leaders
taking real risks
inside their countries.
The historic argument that
the street will rise up
and they'll be rioting
and bad things,
and they'll overthrow regimes
and the Palestinians will
start creating chaos,
they'll be World War
III was very real.
That didn't change, that
perception didn't change.
So yeah, it was
tenuous till the end.
None of these deals are
ever over till they're over.
And we had to get a
lot of moving parts
headed in the right
direction at the same time,
and so there was complexity.
And it took us two and a half
years to actually deliver
from conceptual
idea to execution
on the south lawn of the
White House, a glorious day.
Good stuff for those countries
and important for
our country too.
- What kind of pushback
did you guys get
from that sort of
state that you describe
of these people that
don't change much?
'Cause I had Netanyahu on
about a month and a half ago,
and that's what he
was talking about,
that all of the policy people
said, you do it the other way,
you do the Palestinians first
and then the rest will happen.
But he said, no, we're
gonna try it this way.
And it actually worked.
But in essence, you're
saying these guys,
they don't like
change, so I'm guessing
you're getting pushback
from your own people
as these things are happening.
- Of course.
And you can see that, by
the way, when we leave,
they immediately begin
to fudge a little bit
on where the embassy's gonna be,
whether it's really
gonna be in Jerusalem,
are we gonna have a consulate
there too for the Palestinian?
So, you could see the machine
start to push back against it
even after we leave.
But we certainly suffered that.
We were mocked, right?
Jared's proposal was
called deal of the century,
just dripping with sarcasm.
But in the end, we
understood something
I think that frankly,
Republican and Democrat
administrations alike
hadn't recognized.
We came to believe
that these nations,
the Gulf State Arab nations knew
that the Palestinian
cause was important,
but it wasn't their
highest priority.
That is, I want good
things for the people
that live in Judea and
Samaria, whatever ethnicity,
whatever religion they are,
I want good things for
people in Saudi Arabia
and the Emirates,
but in the end,
we're gonna go
deliver good outcomes.
And Abu Mazen the leader
of the Palestinians
in Judea and Samaria,
he's a terrorist,
and there was no chance that
guy was gonna cut a deal,
so we didn't waste
any time trying
to get a deal done, right,
to draw lines on the map.
We threw that out in the
way that both Bush and Obama
and all of them had
tried to negotiate.
We knew there was a
solution that said,
we're happy to work on
the Palestinian issue,
happy to drive
towards a conclusion,
but in the meantime we're
gonna go deliver peace
in the region. And we did.
- Do you think
either in that region
or really all over the
world that other countries
kind of miss that
American leadership
that does seem to be lost?
As I said, I just
did an hour show
on the World Economic Forum.
We seem to be outsourcing
all of our decision making
to groups that have
nothing to do with our laws
or our founding, or
anything like that.
- I don't have to guess.
I know it to be true.
I still stay in touch
with a handful of folks
around the world
who call me and say,
what the heck is going on?
And it's not even just that.
Dave, it's not even that
we agreed with him always.
We had big knockdown, drag
out fights with friends,
with allies, with
our adversaries.
But you could, when I
was a secretary of state,
you could get me on the phone,
you could have a
serious conversation.
I would tell you very much
what America was gonna do,
how we were gonna behave.
I would listen, I'd take
on board their ideas.
If we could make
it work, we would.
But you didn't have to guess,
you didn't have to wonder,
I wasn't apologizing
for America every day.
I was talking about
America as a force
for good in the world.
And I think that
leadership in the world
is something that these nations,
even those that aren't
particularly friendly to us,
I think those nations miss
that true north anchor
inside the United States.
- Yeah, it's interesting because
our media seems to hate it
more than the countries, right?
The other countries
seem to want it.
That's what you're saying.
But it's our own media,
which seems to actively
despise our ability
to have influence.
- You see this.
You see this in every
element of American policy,
not just in our national
security policy, right?
In our schools,
they're teaching kids
that America's a racist nation.
There's an oppressor
class in our universities.
They can't understand that
there's just two genders, right?
These are ideas that undermine
the central propositions
that have made America so
exceptional for 250 years.
And whether it's in national
security or education at home
or crime, always these
folks are working the edges.
And I've had some folks say,
Mike, you have to compromise.
You were a diplomat, you
have to give an inch.
But the truth is there's
places you can compromise.
If my son wanted to
go to bed at 8:30
and I thought 8:00
was the right time,
8:07 sounds good, right?
But on things that
really matter, the
American value system,
the central
understandings of family,
the idea that this is in
fact the most noble nation
to ever exist in the
history of civil.
On those things, you
can't round the corners.
You can't. You literally,
because once you begin to say,
well, it's a good
point, you're done.
Because they will drive a
truck through the damn thing.
And we just simply
can't let that happen.
- So what do you think
is really going on here
with this globalist
situation and these meetings
that they have in Davos
and all these other places
where a whole bunch of people,
nobody seemingly to
represent the United States,
nobody to represent
the individual.
We send Americans there,
but they very rarely
talk about America.
Actually, on my
show the other day,
we played a clip of 2018
when President Trump went
and he started
talking about America.
And they were not
very happy with him.
What is the actual
influence of these groups?
Like, is it as scary as it seems
when we're watching
these clips on YouTube
and everywhere else?
- I actually think some of this
is just a bunch of gasbags
meeting to have confabs.
- I hope you're right.
- Yeah.
But look, there is a
globalist agenda out there,
it's centered at
Turtle Bay in New York
at the United Nations, right?
That is the hub, that
is the focal point,
that is the quasi-governmental
organization, the NGO
that drives much
of this narrative.
It then bleeds over into human
rights activism from the left
and into American and
global businesses as well
who don't stand up to
the political pressures
that they need to.
But I don't worry
as much about places
that where these
folks go to gather,
some of them are just there
doing commercial deals
that'll end up
being really great
to create tens of
thousands of jobs
for the United
States of America.
I worry about the
United States government
and its unwillingness to accept
that most of these institutions,
the UN, the IAEA, I
could go on, the WTO,
they have undermined
American sovereignty
and we've allowed
that to happen.
And the Chinese have figured out
how to run many of
those institutions.
Those are the places
that actually exert
influence and power
and have the capacity to
shape both American thought
and the way America
engages in the world.
And you don't have to leave
the UN but you better make sure
that you are not permitting
the United Nation
to behave in ways that
undermine America.
And we never allowed
that to happen.
- They could at least pay
their parking tickets, right?
Isn't that a huge
scandal every year?
They don't pay their
parking tickets.
- Yes, they should pay
their parking tickets
and they should stick to
their knitting as well.
- Were you surprised by
Trump's instincts on that
as a guy who wasn't part
of the political class,
that that really was like
one of his main things
from beat one, you guys
are gonna pay what you owe.
We're not gonna foot
the bill on all this.
We're not just gonna give
you endless resources.
That he just kind of got
that right right away.
- Not surprised at all.
He campaigned on it.
He intuitively understood it.
Business guy, came
from the real world.
What do you do? You
pay your bills, right?
And if you don't,
bad things happen.
Have to file bankruptcy, right?
He'd lived all of
that in his life.
No, he understood too that
these things aren't infinite,
so we can survive in America
spending a whole bunch of money
all across the world for
a while, but in the end,
you gotta make
sure you take care
of the things that matter
most to people back home.
And he grasped that in a
way that so many did not.
And I think America was better
off as a result of that.
- So you were secretary
of state during COVID,
and that kind of
changed the world.
Can you talk about
that a little bit?
- Yeah. So, a couple things.
One, I ran a massive airline
for a bunch of months.
We had Americans stranded
all over the world.
We brought back a hundred
thousand plus Americans
who'd had roadways,
buses, airplanes
pulled out from under 'em,
And so we went and tried
to round them all up,
which was amazing work.
That State Department, actually
I gave them full credit
for having managed this process
to help get these people
back home outta tough places.
But more broadly,
it gave us two opportunities
and a couple challenges.
First challenge was, look,
this virus almost certainly
came from the Chinese lab.
And we were immediately,
I think I said this on a
TV show in March of '20,
maybe it was April and,
just pillaring for hate,
I was a racist and
the anti-China racist.
Nope, it came from the
lab almost certainly.
- Also China, Chinese
is not a race,
but that's a different
thing, but okay.
- No. It's all crazy.
- Yeah.
- But even more important
than where it came from,
the Chinese leadership knew
that they had a
pretty contagious,
relatively lethal virus on
their hands by the fall of '19
and decided to put tens of
thousands of people on airplanes
and murder.
And I say that
intentionally, murder
hundreds of thousands of people
all across this country.
They had a choice to make.
The choice they made
was load airplanes
send them to Milan, Italy.
The Chinese Communist Party
must be held accountable
for this.
Look, they don't care
about human life, so be it.
But when you transmit that
to the rest of the world
and you kill people
all around the world,
there's a place for
real accountability.
The good news is I think
Americans came to see
how bad the Chinese
Communist Party really was.
The risk to America,
if we outsourced all
of our manufacturing,
certainly semiconductors
and national security stuff,
but think basic things like
simple pharmaceuticals,
the capacity for our
medical system to operate
without Chinese supply chains.
I think American people can
see that that was a bad idea
and those businesses are
starting to come back to America
and to places that we can count
on to partners and friends.
And that is a good thing.
The last thing was,
COVID had the upshot
of giving parents a
crack and a window
into what their kids were
being taught in schools.
And ain't no mama wants
their kid to be taught
that America is a racist
nation and that math
and science and
reading don't matter.
And I think we've seen a
fundamental transformation about
how parents think
about public education.
They wanna make sure
their kids get a fair shot
at the American opportunity.
And I was all across
the country last year
campaigning for candidates.
It didn't go as well
as I would've hoped,
but I was out there grinding
away listening to folks,
and they are serious about this.
And the fact that we were
all watching more closely
what our kids were up to,
I think is a net good
thing for America.
- Yeah. And by the way,
it's happening right now.
I mean, Kim Reynolds is
doing school choice in Iowa.
Huckabee is gonna be
doing it in Arkansas.
Clearly something good's
happening here in Florida.
But on the first part of
that, when you guys realized
that in essence it
was coming from China,
either fully,
intentionally or not,
or then they were
sending these planes
first to Italy and
then everywhere.
I'm guessing you
got on the phone
with some sort of
Chinese counterpart.
I mean, did they just
stonewall you on everything?
Did they admit anything?
Was there any level of
accountability or anything?
- Total stonewall.
I tell this story, it's
an important story.
As we rounded from 2019
into 2020, the CDC,
they all had
counterparts in China.
And they'd been talking
because there was this rumor
about what was going on there.
And right at the
first of the year,
total shutdown, locked out.
I was asked by Mr. Redfield to
call my Chinese counterpart,
the foreign minister
and the state councilor.
I did. Nothing, not a word.
The World Health
Organization gets shut out
when they tried to investigate.
Sadly, they just bent a knee
and said, Nope, everything,
nothing to see here, folks,
so the WHO failed
the world as well.
But yeah, they went into
complete information lockdown,
hiding from the world what
they most certainly knew
about what had happened there.
- How do you as the
secretary of state coordinate
or work with those, the
WHO, the NIH, the CDC,
all of these things.
I mean, you're dealing
with borders and planes,
and all of that stuff.
Are you directly telling,
are they basically telling
you you've gotta shut borders
and you can't do this,
and you gotta do that?
Like, who's actually in
charge at that point?
- Yeah, so the senior
decisions about
what America was gonna
do in the response
were made by President
Trump himself,
with the advice from me and
from Department of Defense,
from NIH, CDC, all of
his advisors were around,
the vice president led
the response task force.
But in the end, the
big decisions about
whether to close
our borders or not
were made by the president.
- Do you guys think
you botched anything?
I mean, if you
were to look back,
would you have done this
differently or that differently
or advised him
differently, or anything?
- I thought about this a lot.
In perfect hindsight,
you can say
that there was
information we didn't know
or we weren't thinking
about quite right.
I think we got good pieces
of the actual physical
response right.
But I think we got some
of the messaging wrong.
And then as time moved on
and more information
was available,
I think Dr. Fauci did terrible
things by talking about this
in a way that kept
our schools closed
for as long as they did.
We knew that the
kids were unlikely
to have serious large scale
ramifications from this.
We told teachers, Oh,
you can stay home.
When we told nurses
they had to go to work.
They're all important,
but why on earth we didn't
open our schools more quickly?
Why we were so closing
that up and we had churches
and synagogues shut down too
is incomprehensible to me.
- Do you think it's fair to say
that China did
this intentionally?
Maybe not the leak itself,
but that the export of it,
and when you're being
stonewalled in all
of these things.
That this was sort of the plan
to get western democracies
to, in essence turn
against their people,
become a little bit more like
China rather than China become
a little bit more like us,
which is what I think most
people thought was gonna happen,
for the last 30 years,
something like that.
- Dave, you got
it exactly right.
Yes. Absolutely intentional.
At the very least we can argue
knowing versus intentional
as absolutely knowingly sent
this virus around the world.
And from my perspective, the
difference between knowing
and intent is zero in this case.
They intended this virus
to go around and they knew
it was gonna kill people
all across the globe.
What were their
motives for that?
We can all argue about.
I don't know the answer.
But here's what
we know for sure.
A decent nation, a nation
that cared about humanity,
would've opened the doors,
brought in the world's
leading experts,
wouldn't have let
anybody travel,
would've locked down that
virus as best they could
where they found it
and have given them
the global community, and
frankly, it's America,
mostly America's best
scientist the capacity
to understand what
was going on there,
so that you can
develop solutions that
actually make sense.
Not just for China, but
for the entire world.
And they chose exactly
the opposite course.
- So, what do we do about that?
I mean, if that
actually is the case,
let's say you were to have
another job in your future,
perhaps, what do you do
if that really is true?
- It's real.
Don't kid yourself about the
World Health Organization
saving the lives of Americans.
They're not going to, you have
to take this upon ourselves.
We're happy to work with
folks around the world.
These kinds of things
are global problems,
but America's
gonna have to lead.
And we can't do it by
providing a bunch of money
to guys at the World
Health Organization
that don't really give a darn
about the second and
third order ramifications
of their failures.
More broadly for China,
we could talk about this
for an awfully long time.
Republicans and Democrats
alike permitted themselves
the fantasy that
you just described.
We thought they'd
become more like us,
and we've known for
at least a decade,
maybe two, that wasn't true.
And we just let it keep going,
and we let 'em walk all over us.
The Chinese built
their massive economy
on the backs of the
American worker,
and we don't need
to let that happen,
and so I gave a speech
in the spring of '20
that basically said
China's an adversary,
much like the Soviet Union.
Ronald Reagan said,
we win, they lose.
That's what's gonna have
to happen here as well.
We're gonna have to win and
they're gonna have to lose.
We have the capacity to do that.
We should make sure that
China is treated reciprocally.
That is, what's a good example.
The Chinese are trying
to build and buy land
near American
military facilities.
Dave, I'd ask everybody in
your audience, head out,
call your real estate agent,
try to buy land in China near
a Chinese military facility.
Godspeed.
(Dave laughing)
We should not let them-
- They're not giving you
no money down on those.
- My guess is your
realtor's gonna come back
and say that's just a little
pricey. Can't get there.
We should not let them use
our open society against us
in the ways that we have.
And American business,
America's largest
financial institutions
are all gonna have to come
on board, come on sides.
If we need government power to
coax them in that direction,
we've gotta do that.
We've gotta return
to making sure
we take care of working
class Americans here at home.
And when we do, we will take
advantage of all the challenges
that the Chinese have.
They've got issues with
their aging population,
they've got
financial challenges.
They are not 10 feet tall.
But when you lay down for them,
they look like
they're 10 feet tall.
And so, we just simply need
to stand up, push back,
demand a world that
looks more like ours,
a word with Western values.
It means we gotta get it
right here at home too.
If we do those things,
then the Chinese dream
of an American decline
will prove to be just that,
a fantasy and a dream.
- Let me ask you about the
other big global event.
Obviously Russia, Ukraine,
for the term that Trump had,
and while you were secretary
of state, it was pretty quiet.
Under Obama, Russia
takes back Crimea,
but then it's quiet
under you guys.
Now, obviously not so quiet.
What would you be
doing right now?
advising Joe Biden on?
And how do you feel about
this endless blank check
that everybody
basically on both sides,
except for pretty much, I think
Rand Paul and maybe Ted Cruz
and a couple other guys
keep signing off on.
- Goodness. I've been
asked this an awful lot.
It was quiet on our watch
and you have to believe
in a lot of coincidences to
think that we were just lucky.
The truth is, I think
Vladimir Putin understood
that we were different cast
of characters, all right?
When the Iranians were
moving about the cabinet,
we went and took out
Qasem Soleimani, right?
Demonstrating that we were
gonna, in a very nuanced way,
we didn't send 80,000 soldiers.
We didn't go invade any place.
We just sent a message
with absolute clarity
that we were serious and real.
- Was that your, the mother
of all bombs, was that you?
- The strike on
Soleimani was something
that I certainly recommended
to the president.
And I write about this
because it was important
not just to deter Iran, but
Chairman Kim in North Korea,
who I spent way too much time
with, the Taliban, Xi Jinping,
they all say, oh my goodness,
these guys are serious, Pompeo.
These guys are gonna,
if they say they're
gonna do something,
they actually are
going to do it.
And Putin saw that
Biden wasn't that,
and so you lose the bubble
and he invades Europe.
As for what to do today,
every day this goes on,
creates enormous risk
for us, for America.
The risk that he uses a
tactical nuclear weapon,
the risk that he
conducts a cyber campaign
here in the States to
send a message to us.
We gotta get this to end.
I only know one way
to get it to end.
And that is to
provide the Ukrainians
with the tools that they need.
I'm not for blank
checks, but I am for,
if they're prepared to
defend their sovereignty
and risk their own
boys and girls lives,
I'm prepared to
help them do that
against an authoritarian regime
that's killing civilians.
We should then find a solution
that has two features.
One, it's gonna have
to be acceptable
to both the Russian people
and the Ukrainian people.
Everybody talks about
Zelenskyy and Putin.
It's just, there's
a lot going on here,
and so you're gonna
have to find something
that everybody can say, all
right, that is good enough.
No one's gonna get
their maximalist dream.
Second, we need to find a
solution that has a permanency.
And I live in the real world,
nothing's ever permanent,
but think 10, 20, 50
years of permanency.
So that six months or
two years from now,
Putin's not back at this,
or his successor's not
back at this again.
We have the capacity
to use American power,
not our soldier, sailors,
airmen and marines,
but American power to
facilitate a hastier conclusion
to this and a relatively
permanent conclusion.
That should be the American
mission for the American people.
- Is the inherent problem there,
I think sort of two things.
One that, I mean, Putin's
got nukes as you just said.
And to make the guy with nukes
surrender is kind of tough
'cause he's got the
ultimate weapon, number one.
And number two, that if he
doesn't get a win out of this,
if he doesn't get that off ramp,
he doesn't want to
end up like Gaddafi
and basically get stabbed
by one of his own people
on the run for the last
couple weeks of his life.
- Yeah, Dave, it's complicated.
It's complicated for
both leaders, I think.
Each of them have
constituencies.
And it's different,
it's not a democracy.
Nobody's gonna go
hold an election.
But they both have to find ways
that they can move forward.
I suspect that when this ends,
each of those leaders
will struggle to
maintain their power.
The Ukrainians are gonna
all look around and say,
look what happened
to our country.
And the Russians are
gonna look around and say,
look what happened
to our country.
And so, what I think
we should focus on
is not the individuals
but the systems.
Look, Ukraine, there was a
lot of corruption in Ukraine.
The whole time I was
a secretary of state,
we should never blink and
pretend that is not so,
but we should strive
to take a country
that has demonstrated
its willingness
to be an American partner
and try to provide it
with the tools to
protect its sovereignty.
And if we get that right,
we can find a space where
the Russian people can say,
yep, this is quote, good
enough, end of quote.
I'm convinced there is.
Very few conflicts
like this one end
with one side totally
annihilating and
defeating the other.
The handful of cases, maybe
the American Civil War.
We might, someone might
gimme two or three others,
but, boy, there's very few.
They always end up with
some level of compromise.
I'm confident this one
will end that way as well.
And the sooner that happens,
the less destruction in
Ukraine and the less,
most importantly the less risk
to the United States as well.
- I got one more
question for you.
And you know what it is already,
so I don't even have to ask you.
- I'm not gonna tell you
about what's in the UFO files.
Come on. (chuckles)
- Exactly.
That's actually what
I wanted to know.
We can do that one off
camera, but of course.
Look, you wrote this
book, you're on the stump,
people are mentioning your name.
Your former boss has already
announced he's running.
We're almost at the
season where people
are getting in on this thing.
There you go. I'm
giving you a softball.
- We're getting close to
the time, you're right.
Where it's time for those who
want to put themselves forward
to make the case to the
American people to do so.
Susan and I haven't made
that big decision just yet.
We're working our way
to try and figure out
if this is the right
time to do that,
if we should go make that case.
But I believe deeply in America.
I grew up in a family
that understood
the basic decency
of our country.
That fight is something
I intend to stay in.
Whether I end up
seeking political
office again in my life
is yet to be determined.
Only the good Lord knows.
- All right, now gimme a
little something on the UFOs
and then you're free.
(Secretary Pompeo laughing)
- Here's what I'd
say about the UFOs,
we got bigger problems.
(Dave laughing)
- Secretary Pompeo,
I appreciate it,
and if anything is to be
announced in the future,
maybe we'll do this again.
- Bless you, Dave.
Thank you. Have a good day.
- Thanks a lot.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.